Hall of Fame broadcaster Brewers radio
play-by-play announcer since 1971 actor
comedian all-around great guy Bob Uecker
UK are you today it's good to talk to
you how much fun is this season been for
you well yeah you know with the with the
deals they made Dan and the acquisitions
of a couple of guys who have really been
been you know really impact players for
the club talking about Lorenzo Cain and
and Christian Yelich it's been a fun
season for not only not only me but fans
here in Milwaukee and I mean with the
expansion of the rosters and the
up-and-down view you can do with the
with the 10 days to the minor leagues
back up again I mean you got guys moving
all all season long here I mean it's a
constant movement and it was a fun Club
it's a fun Club it's a good bunch of
guys and I think if you if you talk to
anybody connected with the club that's
that's what they tell you it's kind of a
kind of a wee bunch of guys not not too
many hi guys and David Stearns and Matt
Arnold who made Maeby's moved and really
go all out to make a run you know it
came to fruition and here they are
coming back to Milwaukee for the final
three games and a shot at postseason
play for a while who is Christian Yelich
to remind you of Roy Rogers okay-y no
wait the way he plays does he remind
come on goofball no guys you know they
don't come along too often I mean the
guy can run he can play in the outfield
he can throw he hits with power ease in
fer average and he I'm telling you is
one of those guys that never says me
I he doesn't and you know a fun guy to
be around he is I mean the club in
general dan is is a bunch of good guys
the Dominican players
no I don't care worth from it's one it's
one big unit and guys like Asus Aguilar
who who's a huge Duke fun guy
Orlando RC I think is going to be one of
the best shortstops in baseball down the
road here I mean everybody they got on
this club has contributed and and made
it made it really a fun season I mean I
got a little testy every once in a while
you know but for the most part it's been
good it's been a lot of fun how did you
celebrate clinching a playoff berth the
first time in what seven years yeah it
was a little dusty for me my pacemaker
kicked out starting an outboard motor
that got a little but but other than
that it was okay you know I I wrote home
soaking wet and but it was fun everybody
on board was was really nice I didn't
shower because it would have thrown me
off off my game you know at the home we
do that at the home every night I don't
know why the home every night at your
peak what role would you would you play
on this Brewers team I would have
probably been the guy opening the box
that would have been my job as a matter
of fact I might not have been on the
40-man roster at this time well I mean
I'm you know the clubhouse celebration
Dan you you've been around them you know
what they are and and to to do it on the
road and do it and say Louis it was a
little extra special because the
Cardinals knocked him out last year in
that final series in st. Louis and
Colorado went on the wind so it was
little
satisfaction for for the Brewers and the
crew to do it in st. Louis to sweep the
series and now the Cubs and the and the
Cardinals get it on in st. in Chicago
starting tonight and the Brewers have
have Detroit here at Miller Park talking
to Bob Uecker Hall of Fame broadcaster
did you keep all of the tapes your
appearances on The Tonight Show Johnny
Carson do you have the archives of those
appearances no I didn't keep I had such
a good time with Johnny all the time I
didn't I never did anything on that show
Dan to promote anything I had one on one
particular show I was doing that mr.
Belvedere series and I was going to sing
I've changed my mo from a writer to a
singer and I sang on The Tonight Show on
him and and I sang off-key really bad so
Johnny asked me he said when is this
show gonna plan I said Thursday he said
Thursday holy but then I blamed it on
Doc Severinsen that we didn't have a
chance to work out together but no I had
a good time with Johnny all the time
yeah I really did we straight but first
time you go on I I don't know if you get
nervous or not I don't know if going to
the plate you know facing Sandy Koufax
is more nerve-wracking than you know
going on The Tonight Show but if you
were gonna compare the two how nervous
were you going on The Tonight Show first
time and they were still in New York and
I I was a little uptight about it but it
went pretty well
and as we said good night I heard Johnny
I heard Johnny ass but Ed McMahon he
said did this guy really play baseball
[Laughter]
four or five shows a year and always had
a good time with him always but then you
get mr. Belvedere you get the Miller
Lite commercials as well I mean it all
just like there was a there was a time
when you were you and John Madden and
maybe Cosell in there you guys were at
the peak there when I was playing
baseball
my salary was $2,000 under the minimum
you know I had a winter job we all for
the most part when you're playing back
in the 50s and 60s we had offseason jobs
and because you weren't making enough
money unless you were one of the you
know the big guys what was your worst
job season John III worked construction
outside and that was kind of tough I was
I was working on frozen pipes from
laboratories and senior citizens homes
and I've got to be able to attest I mean
your hands are always cold you know I
can't touch yourself either so I mean
wash your face your hands are freezing I
mean it's tough it was a tough job but I
had four kids and I still don't know
where they are chance to play I played
and I played the big leagues and but I
also like to make people laugh if you
got a minute I want to tell you about
one of the great place yes and it was
only a spring training game okay but
still I had a chance to knock in the
winning run against the Orioles down to
Miami there's a runner at third this is
really two outs
I hit a rocket down the third-base line
and I'm going out of the box I know I
got a base head right now I see Brooks
Robinson make a diving stab but he's in
foul territory now I know there's gonna
be a play at first
I see boom pop breaking for the bag
right
so now I really start busting down the
line and I had a little habit of
knocking my hat off with my thumb so it
looked like I was really moving and as I
get close to the bag I was gonna take
the throw now all of a sudden he starts
backing off the bag and I got a basehead
bet I knocked in the winning run and as
I just busted up on the back I see a
glove down there with a ball and it was
Brooks Robinson tag in the bag it's the
only five unassisted
if the Brewers win the World Series
finish that sin don't do that that would
that's on a walk-off for you though is
it if they win the World Series that you
just you would retire if the Brewers won
the World Series could you catch a
pitcher right now you never dropped one
of those though you know no pass balls
hey congrats though been a great run for
this team a lot of fun and hopefully
they generate some excitement here in
the playoffs always great to catch up
with you that's Bob Uecker Hall of Fame
broadcaster and he's been doing it I
think 48 years they've only made the
playoffs seven of the forty eight years
what a treasure though for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
you
[Music]